WE CONTINUE TONIGHT OUR SERIES
FROM AUSTRALIA.
JOHN OLIVER LEARNED THAT
FOLLOWING A MASS SHOOTING IN
STRAUL, THE COUNTRY INTRODUCED
GUN CONTROL, AND IT WORKED.
SO HOW CAN AMERICA TAKE THIS
VALUABLE LESSON AND IGNORE IT?
JOHN OLIVER FINDS OUT IN THIS,
OUR FINAL INSTALLMENT.
>> PREVIOUSLY I WENT TO STRAUL
WHEN I LEARNED IN 1996 THEIR
GOVERNMENT ENACTED SWEEPING GUN
CONTROL LAWS.
THE RESULT-- REDUCED GUN
VIOLENCE AND ZERO MASS
SHOOTINGS.
SO ARE THERE ANY LESSONS FOR
AMERICA HERE?
VIRGINIA GUN ADVOCATE HAS A
CLEAR ANSWER.
>> WE'RE NOT AUSTRALIA.
IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT CULTURE,
DIFFERENT PEOPLE, DIFFERENT
EVERYTHING.
>> THERE'S NO SIMILARITY WITH
AUSTRALIA.
AUSTRALIA IS A FORMER BRITISH
COLONY WITH A WORLD FRONTIER
THAT WAS TAMED BY BRAVE MEN WHO
ALSO WIPED OUT ALMOST AN ENTIRE
INDIGENOUS POPULATION, AND WE
ARE?
NOT SIMILAR TO THAT, RIGHT?
>> RIGHT.
BECAUSE UNLIKE AUSTRALIA, WE
AMERICANS KNOW WHEN THE GUNS ARE
TAKEN AWAY, TYRANNY INEVITABLY
FOLLOWS.
>> THE FOUNDING FATHERS KNEW
THAT GOVERNMENTS TEND TO GROW
BEYOND THEIR MEANS.
IN AMERICA, WE'RE STEPPING IN
THE DIRECTION OF A POLICE STATE.
>> IS THAT REALLY HAPPENING,
PHILLIP, OR IS THAT SOME KIND OF
CRAZY PARANOIA?
>> WE HAVE POLICE.
THEY'RE NOW WEARING NINJA SUITS
IF YOU WILL.
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW THEY'RE
POLICE NECESSARILY.
THEY HAVE THE BLACK MASKS ON AND
EVERYTHING.
>> IT ISN'T CRAZY PARANOIA.
YOU'RE FRIGHTENED ABOUT NINJA
POLICE.
>> NINJA POLICE, YES.
>> YEAH, NINJA POLICE.
>> YES.
>> SADLY WITHOUT ACCESS TO
SEMIAUTOMATIC FIREARMS,
AUSTRALLIANS WOULDN'T BE A THING
ABOUT REAL FREEDOM.
>> BLOODY EARTH IS FOR FREE.
WE'RE SITTING HERE DOING
WHATEVER WE WANT.
EVERYBODY IS JUST HANGING OUT
AND HAVING A GOOD TIME.
>> PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THE SAME
CONCERNS ANY MORE ABOUT GETTING
GUNNED DOWN WHEN THEY'RE IN A
TOURIST RESORT.
>> BUT WHAT WAS THAT WORTH IT?
>> YES.
>> WAS IT WORTH GIVING UP YOUR
FUNDAMENTAL FREEDOMS JUST TO NOT
GET SHOT IN A GUN MASSACRE?
>> WHAT THE ( BLEEP ) ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT?
>> AUSTRALIANS MUST NOW LIVE IN
THIS WELL-REGULATED NIGHTMARE
BECAUSE OF EX-POLITICIANS LIKE
ROB WHO SMUGGLING THINKS HIS
COUNTRY HAS SOMETHING TO TEACH
US.
>> I HOPE THAT THEY WOULD HAVE A
LOOK AT WHAT HAS HAPPENED HERE.
>> WHY WOULD PEOPLE WANT TO LIVE
LIKE THIS?
>> BECAUSE THEY MIGHT WANT A
SAFER SOCIETIA TO LIVE IN.
>> BUT IT'S POINTLESS FOR US TO
STUDY THE AUSTRALIAN EXPERIENCE
BECAUSE THEIR FEAR OF GUN
CONTROL BACK THEN HAS NO
PARALLELS WITH OURS.
WHAT KIND OF THINGS WERE YOU
HEARING WHEN YOU SUGGEST GUN
CONTROL?
>> THAT GOVERNMENT WAS BECOMING
A DICTATORSHIP.
>> THAT'S ONE.
>> WE'RE TOLD THAT PEOPLE WOULD
NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO DEFEND
THEIR PROPERTY AND THEIR FAMILY.
>> ANOTHER THAT'S DEFINITELY
TWO.
>> THAT DEMOCRACY IS AT STAKE
SOMEHOW IF GOVERNMENT DECIDES
THERE SHOULD BE A BACKGROUND
CHECK.
>> ALL RIGHT, THREE.
>> WE'RE ABOUT TO BE INVADED BY
THE INDONESIANS.
>> THAT'S COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
NO ONE IN AMERICA IS AFRAID OF
INDONESIANS.
ARE THEY AFRAID OF MEXICANS AND
MUSLIMS COMING?
MAYBE,.
SURE, HE CLAIMS AUSTRALIANS WERE
ANGRY, BUT WHERE IS THE PROOF?
>> PEOPLE'S RIGHTS ARE BEING
TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE UP ANY
GUNS.
ARE YOU GOING TO GIVE YOURS UP?
>> NO!
>> OKAY, THERE IS IT IS.
BUT HOW DID THE ANGRY
CONSERVATIVES FEEL NOW?
>> MY IMMEDIATE REACTION WAS
THAT IT WAS AN IVORY ACTION BUT
AS TIME WENT ON, THE REGULATIONS
WERE QUITE MANAGEABLE.
>> HOLD ON, YOU DIDN'T WANT TO
GIVE UP YOUR HIGH-POWERED GUN?
>> NO, BUT-- I FELT AS IF I HAD
A BIT OF A DUTY TO THE REST OF
SOCIETY.
>> AND IF YOU THINK THAT SOUNDS
BAT ( BLEEP ) CRAZY, THIS
EFFECTIVE GUN CONTROL WAS
ENACTED BY CONSERVATIVE
OLITICIANS AGAINST THE WILL OFP
THEIR OWN BASE.
OUR POLITICIANS ARE DIFFERENT.
THANE THAT--
>> GUN CONTROL DOESN'T WORK.
>> OR EVEN IF IT DOES--
>> IT TAKES A LONG TIME.
>> AND TO BE FAIR.
>> JOHN HOWARD AND HIS DEPUTY
PRIME MINISTER TIM FISHER HAVE
HAD SINCE 1996 TO ENACT THEIR
SWEEPING REFORMS.
>> IT LOOK LESS THAN THREE AND A
HALF MONTHS.
>> WHAT?
WHAT? !
>> THE MASSACRE WAS ON THE
28th OF APRIL IN 1996.
IN A 12-WEEK PERIOD SHORTLY
FOLLOWING THAT, THE BULK OF THE
LEGISLATION WAS DEVISED,
DRAFTED, DEBATED, AND
IMPLEMENTED.
>> BUT IT DOESN'T WORK.
>> THERE ARE NO MASSACRES SINCE
1996.
>> YOU KEEP SAYING THAT, BUT IT
DOESN'T WORK.
MY HEAD WAS SPINNING.
I HAD TO CLEAR IT THE
TRADITIONAL AUSSIE WAY.
NOT THAT WAY, A WALK-ABOUT.
>> THE SECOND AMENDMENT IS
SACROSANCT.
>> POLITICAL SUICIDE.
>> FROM MY COLD, DEAD HANDS.
>> WHAT THE ( BLEEP )?
AFTER THREE DAYS IN THE BUSH
WITH A GUY THERE A KANGAROO SUIT
IT BECAME CLEAR WHAT THE REAL
ISSUE WITH GUN CONTROL IN
AMERICA IS.
>> IF GUNS AREN'T THE PROBLEM,
FILL, WHAT IS THE PROBLEM?
>> PEOPLE.
>> PEOPLE ARE THE PROBLEM?
>> YES.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
AFTER SPENDING GREAT AMOUNT OF
TIME WITH YOU, PHILLIP, I'M
STARTING TO BELIEVE THAT THAT'S
PARTIALLY TRUE.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> I'M GLAD YOU UNDERSTAND THAT
PEOPLE ARE THE PROBLEM.
>> THAT IS BECOMING JUST
PAINFULLY OBVIOUS.
AFTER INVESTIGATING THE ISSUE ON
OPPOSITE SIDES OF THE EARTH, I
DISCOVERED THAT IF AMERICANS
REALLY DO WANT GUN CONTROL,
THERE IS ACTUALLY ONE THING THEY
CAN DO TO GET IT.
MOVE TO AUSTRALIA.
♪ YOU COME FROM THE LAND
DOWNUNDER ♪ ♪
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ).
>> Jon: JON OLIVER.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.